humanity is at a precipice that we
are not able to control the proclivities
that we have towards destroying
ourselves
that we won't have a future and so the
only thing we'll have is this will
[Music]
[Music]
so
hello and welcome to a theory of
everything i'm luis razo the
director of asam and host of this
channel today we have the guest
brian keating professor keating is the
chancellor's distinguished professor of
physics
at the center for astrophysics and space
sciences
at the university of california san
diego he's a public speaker
author inventor and an expert in the
study of the universe's oldest light
the cosmic microwave background he's
also an
up-and-coming podcaster who has
interviewed some of the most influential
public intellectuals in the world
we talked about his recent book losing
the nobel prize
wherein he describes a personal journey
that brought him to the point of
tasting the nobel prize but then losing
it
we tried to contextualize his book and
his journey
against the background of humanity's
quest for his so-called
theory of everything and agreed that
long-term human survival
is a wise thing to pursue which of
course is the central theme of our
work on this channel we also talked
about the
absolutely disproportionate impact that
the jewish people have had on physics
and on virtually every branch of human
activity and what professor keating
thinks might be the root cause of this
we weren't able to discuss
many of the topics i would have liked to
explore but maybe we'll be lucky enough
to have him on again at some point in
the future
for your convenience i've placed a
timestamp
to our discussion in the video
description i hope you enjoy and thanks
for
bearing with me as i continue to improve
with these exchanges
professor keating welcome and thank you
so much for doing this
oh it's my pleasure louise nice to be
with you
thank you very much it's my pleasure um
so you've written a
wonderful book before we get into the
the details of the book i'd like to ask
you to
contextualize our conversation and the
book
by giving us a quick um kind of overview
of where we are
as a species according to science
beginning for example with the big bang
and where we are now
if you can get you know give us a 30
second or one minute two minutes of yeah
30 second history of
13.8 billion years sure no problem luis
i thought i'm supposed to give the
homework assignments here uh
so i study the origin and evolution of
the universe which is called cosmology
but
most people don't realize there's
another very similar
sounding effect or phenomena
subject called cosmogeny which involves
the study
of the origin of the universe so
cosmology
technically does not cover the way in
which the universe itself got started in
other words
it doesn't discuss the initial
conditions of its own
founding any more than you know biology
is concerned with the origin of life
itself and so it's really more concerned
with the evolution of cosmological
systems according to the laws of physics
which is interesting because cosmogeny
the story of
the origin of the universe is really a
much older subject
and a less uh technical or less precise
field of study meaning that it has
relied traditionally on
perhaps folklore religious text
speculation without without evidence
some conjectures philosophical arguments
from
you know first causes things like that
and
it really is sort of foundational and
it's funny how little
we teach our students about the genesis
of the universe if you will
if there was indeed a single genesis and
that's a hot topic in
physical cosmology uh but also
we we really ignore the philosophical
underpinnings which to me make the field
as interesting as it could possibly be
so
i do study using technology tools
telescopes
detectors how the universe has evolved
and we're trying to push back our
understanding currently our
understanding goes back 13.8 billion
years
to the origin of the elements in what we
call big bang nucleosynthesis
but it's not necessary that the origin
of the
elements was preceded by the origin of
the universe itself
it could be that the universe is indeed
eternal in a certain sense
cycling between successive expansion and
collapse cycles for example
it could be our universe with singular
there's one universe it came into
existence once
or it could be there's an infinite
number of other universes
and they come into and out of existence
almost continuously
in what's known as the multiverse so
these three you know
very fascinating possibilities um
that in some sense are as old as time
itself because we've thought about
uh notions of a singular origin we've
thought about notions of
the eternal universe in a cyclic
universe um
since as old as uh since the beginning
of time and so
i think it's quite fascinating that we
have um
that we have such uh such an ability to
study
technologically uh these things for the
very first time
okay wonderful and if i remember correct
the earth is about four million years
old and
the human species is four billion years
old billion
billion years old billion years old i'm
sorry of course four billion years old
yes
and the human species is in its current
form maybe a hundred thousand or two
hundred thousand years
old and where does your book fit into
this
hundred thousand year old history what's
happening
in the background of your book yeah so
the book losing the nobel prize is
really a memoir of what it's like to be
a scientist
a younger scientist and try to seek and
strive and not to yield as tennyson
would say
in the quest to understand what the
universe is all about perhaps driven by
a more base a more um uh more
venal if you will a desire at first to
want to win the nobel prize
in addition to wanting to understand how
the universe came to be
and that's just part of my honesty in
the book is describing
what i was motivated by in addition to
wanting to understand how the universe
came to
look the way it does what i try to study
in
the laboratory and the telescopes that i
build with my colleagues around the
world on
all seven continents is how the universe
could reveal itself
through invisible forms of light or
radiation
and furthermore if the universe did
experience a singular origin
if the universe did have a cyclical kind
of behavior
the pattern that we see in the universe
is all this light called the cosmic
microwave background radiation
or three kelvin radiation that would be
imprinted with encoded encrypted with
information about its singular origin or
lack thereof
and we call that a type of polarization
the light has a certain ability to be
oriented in different structures and
different patterns that we can
divine if you will using ultra sensitive
telescopes
at the bottom of the world in the case
of the south pole antarctica
where my story in by and losing the
nobel prize takes place or
on the tops of the andes mountains in
chile at uh 5200 meters
above sea level we're trying to build
the world's most sensitive largest
detectors ever made
in order to go after this singular
question of how the universe came to
have the appearance it does today but
there's no guarantee
we may come up empty and in fact these
you know the
the title of the book is an allusion to
the fact that we did
hope and were positioned to win a nobel
prize but you know there's no spoiler
alert needed because we didn't
end up detecting what we claimed we had
detected instead we
detected an imposter an interloper
so you ask where does this fit in in the
you know hundred thousand year history
of the human species as we are today as
homo sapiens
well homo sapien means you know a per
someone who knows that they know
a sapient conscious and
we are now able to think uh not only
ideas about how he came to be but also
to test them using technology
and perhaps for the first time although
maybe not
be able to understand how exactly the
universe came to have the appearance
that it does have
excellent when i read the book i was
struck by two
different lines if you were one is a
more personal
line and the other is kind of about the
history
of a tension between those who would
have
humans at the center of existence
a physical existence versus those who
would
say that humans are absolutely
insignificant
can you i think you called it the great
debate can you
run us through uh that aspect of the
book i found it so fascinating
starting with galileo and copernicus
right yeah it's fitting that you
mentioned it because this year
1920 uh 2020 marks the hundredth
anniversary of what was originally
called the great debate
and that uh is a is a subject of a
section of the book as well
and that debate took place in washington
dc in the halls of the united states
capital uh basically to to settle the
question once and for all of whether or
not the
milky way was a galaxy so we take it for
granted that we live inside this
island of hundreds of billions of stars
called the milky way galaxy but back
then it wasn't known
if there are other galaxies in addition
to the milky way
or if our galaxy was the entirety of the
universe itself
they called that the great debate that
was 1920
and it wasn't settled in 1920 they never
really came up with a definitive answer
until hubble famous edwin hubble
discovered that the universe
uh had other galaxies within it and we
could measure the distances to these
galaxies
and they were larger than the size of
the milky way galaxy
itself and then a few years and that was
in 1923
so the great the so-called great debate
wasn't settled until
three years after the actual debate
itself
uh but i claimed there were actually uh
preceding debates at least two other
debates before that
the first one by copernicus and galileo
namely whether or not the sun goes
around the earth as was perceived
and claimed for literally thousands of
years beforehand
or whether the earth instead is a planet
and goes around the sun
and that took place in the 1600s and was
really not definitively settled until
galileo observed the moons of jupiter
which were clearly orbiting the planet
jupiter not the sun or not the earth but
then
it it was almost inconsistent you could
not hold
that jupiter was orbiting sorry the
moons of jupiter
were orbiting around the earth they
certainly weren't and so that caused a
lot of dismay
but actually galileo was famously uh you
know put on trial by the inquisition
much later in 1634 after publishing a
book called the dialogue
and that was really trying to settle the
debate once and for all
in favor of copernicus and that's the
subject
of another talk i do i do speak about
that in the book
but but really the next great debate
that took place after galileo discovered
the moons of jupiter
and that they clearly weren't orbiting
around the earth
an astronomer named william herschel in
the 1700s
made a map of the milky way galaxy and
put the earth at the center of that
structure
rather the solar system by then it was
realized and accepted
that the sun was the center of the solar
system but it wasn't known where the
center of the galaxy was
but he made a map of the galaxy in the
sun at the center of that map more or
less
so it was almost as if well we're not
the center of the solar system but we
could at least be the center of the
galaxy
later on we realized after the great
debate that i discussed in 1920
we realized that the center of the milky
way was actually quite far away from
where we were are located in the outer
disk of the milky way galaxy
uh and then furthermore people began to
realize that we're not even the only
galaxy there is so that was another
debate there's literally
hundreds of billions of other galaxies
each containing hundreds of billions of
other stars
and so it's quite fascinating to then
make the next
logical leap and say well if we're not
the center of the solar system not the
center of the galaxy
we're not the only galaxy we're not the
center of the universe
and so that was hubble's discovery that
the universe is expanding from
every observer's perspective meaning
that the universe is smaller in the past
will be bigger in the future but we're
not the center of it at all
that's the fourth great debate and then
the fifth great debate is
now maybe we're not the only star planet
uh galaxy maybe we're not the only
universe
and that's the current great debate uh
but i don't think we're
you know reaching the end of the great
debates i think there could be great
debates about
the laws of nature the the underpinnings
of quantum mechanics
things you're interested that i know uh
are there one set of laws that apply in
uh our observable universe because we're
here to observe it
uh are there other universes in time
in space in time and space and dimension
and these are all fascinating great
debates that i claim will continue for
the future you can imagine great debates
is it true that carbon is the only way
to form a living organism some say you
could get
all the properties of life uh using
silicon
namely computers can simulate life and
maybe even simulate
us right now having this conversation so
it's fascinating to contemplate all
these debates
are part of this grand tradition of
science to to inquire
to test to refine and hopefully come up
with new ideas to test
measure and refine fantastic
well one of within this uh these great
debates or the current great debate or
the tension between these two
um ways of thinking about human
existence
there is this quest to unify
uh general relativity with quantum
mechanics they like they're speaking two
different languages
and you've had some very very
fascinating discussions recently with
people like eric weinstein and
wolf from about this
attempt to unify general relativity in
quantum mechanics
can you tell us where does this where do
these conversations
fit into this tension uh between
whether or not humans exist at the
center of
of reality or not yeah uh so
that i came to after the book obviously
this is something i've been doing in the
in this 2020 time period in honor of the
100th anniversary of the great debates
but i found it quite interesting to
engage with
uh people who think about the quantum
nature of the universe
there are some who say there is no need
for a
quantum theory of gravity a so-called
theory of everything that would unify
all the lower or higher energy
or higher strength forces of nature the
two nuclear forces
and the force of electromagnetism we
know
that electricity and magnetism are
unified
in a in the electromagnetic theory
that was known in maxwell's time we know
that the weak theory
and electromagnetism are unified in the
electroweak uh
concept there's uh grand unified
theories that
attempt to unify strong force with the
electroweak
uh force and uh creating different
mathematical representations
and moving away from all physical
reality in other words you can model
these things purely based on their
mathematical properties
and the question is why is gravity so
different and distinct why is it
impossible seemingly so to just take the
same
procedures that we've used for the
nuclear forces for electromagnetism
and apply that to gravity and there's
many different approaches to it
which means that someone's got to be
wrong if somebody's right
then a lot of people are wrong but there
is also a question of is it
even necessary to unify gravity with
quantum mechanics
and there's two realms in which quantum
mechanics and gravity
could be required to be unified
one is at the center of a black hole
where there's so-called singularity
we don't really understand singularities
we don't understand the properties of
something that's infinite
that then tapers to something very
gracefully that's finite so for example
near the center of a black hole inside
at the very center of it we have no idea
what that
uh matter and space time are even like
but it could be that the curvature of
space time is
infinitely curved and in other words the
radius of curvature is infinitesimal
but we but we know at great distances or
even not so great distances
that you know if you replace the sun by
a black hole
uh we wouldn't notice it gravitationally
for
you know for basically as long as
possible we keep orbiting around the sun
and so would the other planets and so
the effects of
a black hole at distance is much much
greater
than the so-called schwarzschild radius
are
basically irrelevant to classical
dynamics that we observe
so how do you go from an infinite uh
gravitational potential
uh infinitely deep to a finite
gravitational potential how do you go
from infinite gravitational forces
to finite gravitational forces over a
very short distance
it's very bizarre so it's safe to say we
don't understand that that's
region one where you'd like to have a
quantum
description of gravity and i think you
can
safely say that that wouldn't
necessarily mean that you have a theory
of everything
if you understood it might mean that it
might require that you have a theory of
everything
but it might not you might have
something that only applies to black
holes
and you might be able to do it purely
classically in other words not need
quantum mechanics
the other regime in which you need to
have quantum mechanics unified with
gravity
according to many purveyors of these
theories is in the extremely early
universe
if there is a singularity of space time
uh
where the universe comes into existence
spontaneously
x nilio from nothing it may be
and it seems to be required in that
circumstance
uh that the universe has some way of
making gravity play nicely with quantum
mechanics because
the sky scale the universe the the
properties of space-time itself may be
quantized
and so we don't understand how that
could behave now i said
two things one is that we need to do
that if there was a singularity in the
case of the black hole
and or if quantum gravity is necessary
to describe a black hole
of course we may never be able to detect
that but
also you may may not be necessary for
the universe to have
undergone a quantum event
at the origin of our current observable
universe in other words
if our universe came from a preceding
universe's collapse
that collapse doesn't have to collapse
to an infinitesimal singularity
uh there are people working on paul
steinhardt and collaborators on a purely
classical
bouncing cosmology where the universe
goes from
from a pre-existing state in a prior
universe
perhaps an infinite number of those
universes but and collapses down but not
necessarily to a point
and that's very important because in
that case you don't need quantum gravity
either
so i have found it very interesting this
summer to think about whether or not we
need a theory of everything or whether
it's just kind of this
this extension of as you said
combining you know this notion that we
are special in some sense and that we
understand things relative to our
existence
that maybe we don't need a theory of
everything i don't mean that people
should
stop thinking about it but that combined
with some other observations i made this
summer
including the proliferation of models of
theories of everything
led me to believe that it's not an open
and shut case
that we have to demand a theory of
everything exist
ah very interesting well i'd like to
connect this
these same questions because they're so
abstract and
apparently removed from everyday human
concerns
so i'd like to connect them or try to
connect them
back to your book and the other half of
your book is a very
personal journey and at the end of this
personal journey
where you talk about losing the nobel
prize in a in a very exciting
way you end with the concept of an
ethical will
and you say that this is probably the
most important lesson
to to take from your experience
and that you'd like to pass on in this
same line of reasoning
trying to connect these two i've found
an enormous gap between
scientists and especially physicists at
the cutting edge
and things that really matter to humans
there's this enormous gulf
so as an outsider i always like to say
wait a minute
we need to connect the two especially
telling in this regard
is your recent conversation with
jim simons in the
final minute of the podcast you asked
him
if he could send a message out into
into the universe uh for future
generations or for
other types of um living beings
what kind of message would would he send
and uh i was very struck and i very
moved and agreed very much with his
answer he said that
the most important science is political
science
because if we don't change the way
things are now we're we're going to
cease existing so
how do you connect your ethical will
with these big
questions or do you connect um these
moral questions with these scientific
questions
yeah yeah it's become a very big
excuse me it's become a very big um
topic of
consideration for me as i think about um
you know upcoming projects and and these
conversations that i have with
these luminaries ranging from jim simons
freeman dyson
and then younger folks like eric
weinstein etc
noam chomsky what am i going to derive
from them
that is not already known by simple
wikipedia searches so
you could you could be i remember once
you know
realizing that you could actually pass
any test in undergraduate physics
if you just memorize you know 5 000
different facts like
different constants different equations
and and you may not be able to
derive them but you could you could
basically effectively pass any
undergraduate
first level physics classes and that
made me think you know well
what's the difference between a computer
and at that time wikipedia didn't exist
but
effectively wikipedia has all these
answers to basic
questions about knowledge uh and science
itself the word science you can correct
me if i'm wrong i unders
i assume that you understand latin
language is better than i do because i
don't understand them at all but but
but the word science derives from the
word knowledge siencia
in latin is meaning knowledge but what
it does not mean
is wisdom so wikipedia has a tremendous
amount of knowledge but it has zero
wisdom
because it's just a repository of facts
i started thinking
people are so focused on things like
artificial intelligence
what we really need is artificial wisdom
or maybe even more natural wisdom
and so how can you do that and i started
thinking about in terms of legacy as i
explored in my book but really i've been
doing it more lately
what kind of legacy do you want to leave
that's not tangible material you know
jim simons is
a wealthy billionaire um i don't need to
know how he's going to leave his his
actual
dollars he's going to donate almost all
of it it turns out to scientific
charities
but the question of uh whether or not
he's going to leave
ethical wisdom is much more interesting
to me
as a legacy and as you said you know he
basically feels that
humanity is at a precipice that we are
not
able to control the proclivities that we
have towards
destroying ourselves that we won't have
a future
and so the only thing we'll have is this
will or we'll have this
information that will carry on into the
future
but it won't necessarily provide um
anyone
you know to anything of value because we
won't be here
to kind of glean it so part of the
presumption of leaving a will
is that you have some heirs and you have
some people
that will benefit from your money or
from your gifts or from your wisdom
and so um i agree with him and actually
eric weinstein's expressed the exact
same sentiment
in different uh in a different podcast
that i did with him
that he's very concerned that we won't
uh we actually
are on the precipice of destroying
ourselves much more quickly than i think
jim simons is
namely that the power of the atom the
power of the d
of the cell you know to do a biological
uh you know to affect us biologically
through this awful pandemic that we're
seeing
but also the atom and then the bit you
know so it's kind of like the cell
the atom the power of the atom bomb the
cell
the power of dna to potentially do harm
and crispr
and modified dna et cetera and then the
power
of the bit uh the computer to perhaps
uh have runaway artificial intelligence
scenarios that
people like elon musk and max tegmark uh
have talked about
so these three things really could
conspire in some awful scenario
according to many of these gentlemen but
the question of will we allow it to
happen
and can we be wise enough by thinking
about
our ethical will i claim we can avoid
suicide you know that we can avoid
killing ourselves if we think about how
meaningful it is
to give something to the future whether
it be monetarily
whether it be technologically or whether
it be wisdom
i think by doing that we will kind of
have a little bit of an insurance policy
against committing suicide in the sense
that our
civilization could go extinct and so i i
found that to be kind of a new mission
that i'm trying to undertake
rather than just saying well here's how
many megatons the bomb is and it could
destroy this city or whatever
no think instead of like your children
your children's children
the future of the civilization of the
human race
i think that can be more than just raw
numbers about
uh the destructiveness of the technology
that we've unleashed without perhaps
having the wisdom to control it fully
well very true very true i um so i
always propose as a first principle of
of every branch of human knowledge is
the idea that it's better for humanity
to survive
than it is for humanity to go extinct
so i think any any and every idea can
and should be
judged according to this barometer
uh so for example if you have two
competing theories of everything
or two competing um theories of how to
reconcile
quantum mechanics and general relativity
if one of them
leads us to a more promising way or
or a wiser way to live as a species
then that particular proposal
is obviously um better
than one that has nothing to say about
that
um i think i'm reminded of richard
feynman
who said something to the effect that
stories and how we tell stories and how
we interpret math
in physics matters uh i think he was
talking in particular about the um
dirac picture versus the schrodinger
picture versus the heisenberg picture
and that any good physicist always has
these multiple interpretations
in his head because he never knows where
the next breakthrough is going to come
from
would you think do you think this is a
fair assessment of of
how to interpret the various theories of
everything
one of the various ideas and projects
that were that we're taking on now as a
species
that the priority should be looking for
ways
to not bomb ourselves out of existence
does that seem reasonable well it isn't
it
isn't i mean i don't i don't necessarily
believe that
you know there is a panacea where you
know by merely
contemplating even contemplating our
ethical will or contemplating
mathematics uh etc can really confer
wisdom you know thinking about this
pandemic i don't know how it is
over there in europe necessarily but um
you know we we've had a lot of different
uh discussions about this which have
really impacted
uh and touched upon the role that
science
and scientists can play in the
uh in the managing of something global
that has potential
threat to a large fraction of humanity
and
you know i've kind of been a little bit
dismayed in that exactly to the contrary
of jim simon's advice
the politicians are now completely
abdicating
uh their authority to scientists
now that's kind of unusual because i'm a
scientist you'd think oh i'd like to
have a lot of power noah
we don't elect scientists to be our
politicians
we elect politicians to seek advice and
counsel and you are a management expert
as i understand it
um so you you don't want if you're
managing
a soccer team you don't want the players
to manage the soccer team
you if you're managing a factory for
apple you don't necessarily want the
computer programmers to manage the
company
they have different skill sets they have
different uh optimization functions
against which they try to find a perfect
equilibrium
and so i'm a little concerned when i see
you know people deferring complete
authority politically
you know to set set policy political
power
uh to scientists i think they should
listen to scientists
but people should know the scientist is
very iterative and and self-correcting
hopefully
but it takes a lot of time and i think
people are demanding i mean imagine if
you
demanded that you had um you know a
quantum computer
uh that would be a smartphone you know
that's based on quantum computing
and you demanded it has to be here or
people's lives are going to be at stake
or people's
you know bank accounts you couldn't
encrypt any transaction and so
you demand you know the world's in chaos
and so you demand physicists come up
with this and then you ask the physicist
to determine like well who should have
it should a terrorist have
uh quantum increa on decryptable
self so get into all these problems but
i think
um i i think trusting a little too much
in science can be
can be a false uh based on a false
premise
uh interesting you're right that is kind
of surprising but i see your point
um it's i think it's a valid point at
the same time it's also a little scary
because
to entrust human existence to
politicians
also seems seems like a challenge at the
very at the very least
yeah certainly you know you have to
strike some balance so you hope that you
have
you know wise leaders who are um
you know who who will take advice and
counsel
and won't uh be driven surely by
um you know by by the you know
the desires and the trappings of power
very interesting i'd like to transition
now um to
well along the same lines um there has
been
an incredible contribution a
disproportionate contribution
to various branches of of science by the
by the jewish people and i have a great
admiration for the jewish people
uh you yourself are are jewish of course
i'd like to ask you
where the role or or how do i how your
identity as a
jewish person um fits into your
into your personal life and into your
work keeping in mind
you know the the great names that that
uh in science and not only in science
but in all branches of
virtually all branches of human activity
beginning with the old testament
of through the cutting edge of
theoretical physics
yeah it's very interesting because um
when you think about how
science has been influenced by the
scientific method which i said before
is the cornerstone of progress in
science
the jewish method you know as i call it
it's sort of a scientific method in
judaism
which is also adversarial so you're
probably familiar with the most famous
book
in history you know i always joke i'd
love to have one percent of what god had
for his book sales on the bible
the bible is the most important book to
the to the jewish people in judea or
christianity
however there's a second book which is
almost equally important and that's
called the talmud the talmud means
teaching or or method of teaching and
it's 2700 pages long
so if you read one page a day it takes
seven years to complete this book and
people do that they read one page a day
and the way that the organization of the
book is structured
is uh via argumentation so it will take
a passage from the old testament
and and you'll have people argue about
it so for example most famous one is an
eye for an eye
so you know let me ask you luis do you
think that's meant to be taken literally
like
um you take out my eye and then i go in
and take out your eye do you think
that's meant to be taken literally i'm
curious
no obviously not no no no right so beca
because they even the first sentence
that they that they say in the talmud
there are all these rabbis and scholars
debating it like the first thing they
say is this was never taken
literally because it's impossible to do
the exact amount of damage
to your eye as you did to my eye uh
and so you know because you're gonna
have different pain like if you
hurt my eye accidentally you i didn't
know when you were gonna hit my eye and
maybe i passed out but you know i'm
gonna take out your eye you're gonna
have a lot more psychological trauma
so it was actually meant monetarily and
it was meant as an equalizer to say that
a king's eye
you know if you took out the eye of a
king and you were a slave
uh you were put to death in many ancient
cultures
but this was meant to say no you would
be forced to make recompense
financially and so all these debates go
back and now you can argue that's still
not good you know or whatever but
but the point is the scientific method
of the talmud
is adversarial so one rabbi will say no
it meant literally you know take out the
eye or whatever no one
one said no it meant that um if you hurt
your slave you have to pay for his
eye and of cour unfortunately had a form
of slavery it's more like indentured
servitude we don't have to get into that
right it wasn't like we had an
awful treatment of africans in
americans in in the south in america uh
it was
it's not related to that but uh the the
notion of like how what do you owe your
your people that work for you how do you
or people that that manage that you're
managing
um and what what about you because
people would volunteer themselves to be
what we call slaves but really
it's a form of servant and so how do you
treat them if you had a pillow
but you only had one pill you had to
give that to your servant you could not
keep that for yourself to sleep on so
all these things are debated back and
forth the meaning of these things were
debated back and forth
and i think personally some of that
tradition seeped into the jewish
consciousness
of scientists that were jewish and great
jewish scientists
in history they had this kind of
um dissatisfaction with the status quo
einstein being you know prototypical
feynman being another one they were
anti-authoritarian
uh which which is interesting because
the word
you know we don't think about people
that are jewish and practicing as jews
do
we don't think about them you know as
saying oh well i'm gonna do whatever i
want i
i don't like authority the ultimate
authority is god after all at least if
you're a believing
per religious practitioner so um
but actually the word israel you may not
know this means to struggle
against god so it's really the tradition
of judaism is
fighting against authority and i think
that's a beautiful thing
for science to take into account that
you don't
accept anything on blind faith in
science you argue against it even
einstein even feinman
were wrong and you can be unafraid
to pursue your own ideas because
there's no god of physics and so i think
you're right i think there is
an influence of the jewish tradition of
learning and exchange that is imprinted
on jewish scientists
well very fascinating thank you very
much i wish we could cover so much more
i want to respect your time one final
question
if you could if you could tell us
do you have a preference for any
particular
interpretation of quantum mechanics and
or
uh theory of everything where do you
feel like this is
this is going i think um you know
controversial uh
you know i i am at some level the kind
of copenhagen
shut up and calculate school where i
like to get results
um in terms of the interpretations of
quantum mechanics i know it's it's it's
incomplete
uh there's something about many worlds
that's uh unappealing to me
uh the fact that it's it seems to be
untestable although i did an interview
with sean carroll on my podcast
and into the impossible you can find on
youtube under dr brian keaton
uh that uh you know he was trying to
make some cases
that you could actually establish
experimentally the existence of many
worlds
um uh alternatives but uh i didn't find
it particularly convincing at the time
i confess i haven't looked as deeply
into it as i could
uh so i i i think about it but it's not
something i think about
quite as much as as people like sean
carroll or adam becker or other people
on the other hand i'm very interested in
theories of everything with the
expectation that there's no guarantee
to find a theory of everything that
doesn't preclude us from looking so i'm
actually
working with eric weinstein he's been to
ucsd where i am in san diego
and we've been talking about
collaborating
and mentoring students and if people
want to help
they can help us you know do things like
you know kind of learn more about his
theory of geometric unity
i'm trying to get him to actually write
something up to illustrate something
about geometric unity on the web and uh
we'll have to see if he actually goes
through with it but if anybody has
anything
on the web leave it in the comment
section below uh if you can do some
illustrations
or of some of the advanced concepts that
eric has
and stephen wolfram has a complementary
approach
but uh which involves things that more
akin to neural networks or to um
or or to um you know these economy
diagrams etc
uh but it's not clear so my feeling is
let's let a thousand
flowers bloom very interesting thank you
very much luis i'm gonna have to
run to the laboratory uh but it's been
great talking to you let's keep in touch
and and i can't wait to see where
this goes from here we'll do a part two
thanks so much for your time have a
great day thank you louise have a great
weekend bye bye
if you like what you heard stick around
and let's reason together